hi everybody it's morning here I don't
know what it is where you are
but wherever it is I hope you're doing
well
I'm going to speak you this morning
about the achievement habit which is the
title of a book I just wrote and
basically it's it's we're phrasing this
morning as a guide to you as a doer and
what I mean by I do and what I mean by
achievement is a little bit unusual I
don't mean becoming king of the universe
and I don't mean necessarily doing
extraordinary things I mean doing your
life in a way that's supportive of
whatever your purposes are and so I'm
really talking to everybody no matter
how you use you you think of yourself so
let's get started I'm making an
assumption I'm assuming that you're
behaving your relationships can be
transformed and that assumption is valid
if you want to do it it's not valid if
you don't want to do it and I also want
to know that you can choose to create
habits that make your life better so
that underlines what the basis of what
I'm going to tell you is about and I'm
going to use something called design
thinking and design thinking is a
process for behavioral change that can
be used for transformation that's the
way I'm going to think of it now there
are lots of ways of portraying this this
is just one of the standard ways we use
the first step is if you're going to
solve a problem or do something is to
empathize with what whoever it is you're
designing for or ever is you're solving
for if it's for yourself you have to
sort of empathize for you with yourself
the next idea is to define whatever the
issue is you're trying to deal with and
then to generate ideas and then to
prototype your solutions and ultimately
to test them now join us in this funky
way because it is not a linear process
we use it as a linear way to teach
people but in fact in reality it never
kind of works that way and at any point
any one of these boxes can appear
anywhere else so that's one thing to
keep in mind the other thing I want to
really emphasize in my mind that the
important thing is this plus the
mindsets which means that there are
mindsets that go with this it's not just
a matter of a bunch of tools and you
just go through by the numbers and the
mindsets are very important there's also
other ways to portray these and here's
another set that is used sometimes where
we sort of break up the first two into
three things so we have understanding
first then we have observe and then we
have we form what's called a point of
view and this kind of reflects back if
you want to just go back for a second to
the previous one what we've done is
we've just taken empathize and define
and broken it into three steps the last
three are the same in both diagrams the
nice thing about this diagram there are
all these lines going every which way
again emphasizing it's not a linear
process and it emphasizes this whole
idea of empathy for whoever you're
working with us being in the heart the
root of the whole process but to me the
most important thing on not those boxes
at all it's the idea of what I call the
mind sets and one of the mind sets which
is really important is what we call
human centered and I'll give you
examples later on to make it clear just
how this applies and the other thing
which is really important is what we
call a bias towards action and that is
not thinking things to death before you
move but once you have an inkling of
where you want to go you move and we
know you're going to do something wrong
we know you're going to fail and to
learn how to profit from that so that
you actually move ahead more quickly
ultimately even though you have to take
a few steps backwards we also have the
idea of radical collaboration we're not
in this alone and even on your own
personal issues you're not in it alone
and if you learn how to use other people
you're twice as strong as if you did it
all on your own well we have a culture
of prototyping which is just trying
stuff out and with that we have what we
call show don't tell or it's just so
let's do something about it don't just
give me your ideas about it and all the
time be mindful of your process if
you're mindful of your process you can
keep changing and you can keep improving
it so these are kind of
tools in the background we're going to
bring into play in dealing with our
issues and I want to give you an example
of what I call a human centered approach
to derive a point of view which is
essentially getting a problem statement
and formally speaking it can take many
many different forms but the form that I
think makes the most sense is you start
with a phrase describing a specific user
and it's usually a noun phrases it's a
person a name of a person or type of
person then there's a verb phrase
specifying a need what does you want to
do and then the key is an insight a
phrase giving an insight specifying what
but not how the solution needs to be
accomplished to be concrete here's a
specific of too many slides ahead here's
an example so an example of a point of
view a problem statement might be a poor
single mother needs financial know-how
so she can use her money efficiently so
the insight employed in this point of
view is that poor single moms lack
enough financial know how to use their
money efficiently if this is not valid
even a large increase in our financial
know-how might not produce a more
efficient use of full of funds so it's
important that the piie of you reflect
the person's actual need for a solution
okay so that's that's an example of a
type of thing we're talking about and
you can working on your own problems you
can if raise them in terms of a point of
view now what happens is that we get
stuck we have a problem we get stuck all
of us lose sleep working on problems in
our minds you get problems from work you
have problems in your life you have
problems with your family you have
problems with your co-workers you your
life is full of problems that's the
human situation and most of us are smart
enough to get them done every day you've
got to be you got to this webinar I got
here
Subic lis addressed properly or
improperly forever you are you you eat
enough food but most of a million
problems a day and we never think about
it but every once while we get stuck and
very bright people get stuck the
brightest
people I know get stuck and I've noticed
over the years that the odds are that
what you the reason you're stuck is that
you're treating a wrong answer as a
right question
in other words you don't really have a
question you think you have a question
but you really have chosen an answer and
it's not something you can implement so
you bang your head against this thing
which is just the wrongheaded thing to
do and if you understand that you can
get unstuck and the question is how how
could do you think you can get unstuck
well I have one method I want to tell
you about that I write about that's
actually works very very well and it's
very simple there are many methods and I
talk about those but the one that I
think is is the one most worth knowing
about and easiest to apply is the
following so let's take an example let's
say you want to find a spouse and
nothing works you've gone on the
internet you've gone you've been
introduced by various people you've gone
to every pickup joint you know etc etc
and just nothing works so you have a
problem and you're losing sleep over
this problem so what I would say is ask
yourself what would it do for you if you
found the spouse so if you solved your
problem what would it do for me now
there are many answers let's say for
example your answer is that you want
companionship so you want to find a
spouse in order to get companionship so
now forget about finding a spouse the
problem the real problem you want to
work on is getting companionship so if
you look at that problem immediately
your solution space has opened up
tremendously so in addition to finding a
spouse as a possible solution you might
need friends online you might take
classes you might get a pet you might
join a club etc etc etc so you have this
very solution space and often at this
point you get unstuck you just look at
the problem and in it it will turn out
if you had a hard time here it will turn
out probably if you found a spouse you
wouldn't work you wouldn't have
companionship for example my wife of
only 60 years keeps complaining I'm
never home she I don't give a
companionship Here I am talking to you
instead of being home with making
breakfast for her so she made a bad
mistake okay don't make the same mistake
okay and this opens it up and it's just
so simple so this method is simply if
you're stuck ask yourself what would it
do if you got unstuck what would you do
if you solve your problem for you and
that becomes your new problem and often
your original problem disappears now the
thing that you have to understand and a
lot of people especially Stanford
undergrads have problem understanding is
that disappearing a problem is much
better than solving it if a problem
disappears in your life it's gone
usually forever if you solve it it can
come back to bite you so in my previous
example finding a spouse is gone forever
if you find companionship some other way
you don't have to worry about it's never
going to come back you have to worry
about divorces you have to worry about
getting married six times you can just
go on with your life and have you
companionship in every good way and this
holds with more serious problems
although that may be a very serious
problem for you but this holds in any
kind of problem usually you you let go
of the first problem because it's
meaningless to you and you find a new
problem so I'm going to give you a few
examples that have occurred in my work
at the d.school and and then we'll get
back to tools that you can use so this
is a problem
water pump a treble water pump that's
some students designed for Myanmar we've
sold over 80,000 of them and it's been
very successful but what happens is the
people in Myanmar decide they want
bigger and bigger pressure heads so they
kept raising these pumps higher and
higher off the ground and they were
often the children using it and it got
scarier and scarier scary to see them so
the problem was how do we get the people
up there in a safe way and then someone
said well what would what could we do
why would I do that
and they rephrase the problem and the
solution becomes leave leave the people
on the ground and here's the solution
that they found is they put the pump way
up here to actually made out of plastic
amount of metal and they made a bicycle
chain all the way up and down and the
Mugler can sit on the ground and
humph treadle away all day and they got
a bigger pressure head so we just
reframed the problem another example Oh
gross away also involved the pump one of
the teams went one of the early teams
went to me and ma to work on water pumps
and while they were in the farmers huts
doing empathy work they noticed it was
very hard to breathe because the farmers
were using kerosene lamps and candles
for lights and task lighting and they
found out that it was a the kerosene was
very expensive it consumed about 20% of
the farmers meager income and secondly
was toxic so they figured look it won't
do anything if we get these people water
if they're going to get sick and all
that the real problem is how do we get
these people healthy task lighting so
they went and designed LED lights with
the solar power and they sold millions
of them now
by finding the right a useful problem to
deal with another example which is sort
of iconic in the d.school
is an NGO from from Nepal came and they
have these incubators for premature
children which are essentially the same
as we have in the hospitals at Stanford
they cost around $20,000 and they need
electricity all the time and they have a
lot of parts and in Myanmar they were
breaking and they were finding it hard
to maintain them and the supply of
electricity is intermittent so there
were these two issues and the student
started to work on the problem by making
less parts redesigning it so it wouldn't
be as complicated and putting battery
backups there and when the students went
actually went to Nepal they found that
in fact this was the team force for
hapless Stanford students and they and
they were very motivated because there's
over 20 million low birth weight
children each year $450 hours that's a
strong motivator and when they went
there they found that it's that the that
they had the wrong problem because what
they were they found is that they were
desperate parents in remote villages who
cannot access a major hospital so even
if he's incubators work the people who
need them couldn't get to
so what they needed was something that
gives their dying babies a chance to
survive so they redefined the problem
and came up with something which looks
like this is various prototypes and that
looks like a sleeping bag and inside it
they put a bladder of a wax like
material that's when you heat it up it
changed space and it kept the
temperature for about four and a half
five hours it kept exactly the body
temperature you want so you can heat
this bladder by electricity if you have
it but you could also do with boiling
water or many other means you can to
warm it and that kind of solved the
problem by reframing it of not how do
you fix the incubators so keep the
incubators work but how do you keep the
babies warm which is the real problem
and even if you solve the problem to fix
the incubators it still wouldn't have
solve the problem of keeping the babies
warm because the babies couldn't get to
the incubators so it gets this whole
idea of being stuck with the wrong
solution and now they were this selling
these things all over the world they're
giving them away and they've they're up
to something like sixty thousand babies
already but the other thing I want to
point out this is sort you have to read
this but it's a sort of a graph of the
time line on this project and what I
want you to see is they started and the
team started on this problem in January
2007 and they weren't really launched
through all that into 2011 so everyone
thinks well I got a great idea and
that's it
well folks I got big news for you that
happens very very rarely there's
something that goes between the great
idea and getting it out there and that's
called hard work and that's the biggest
creativity tool in the world hard work
and something called
intention to do what you want to do and
give me an attention I'll get back to
that later so in addition in addition to
designing this it turns out that they
know to some friends of these they
wouldn't notice that there were a lot of
children being born
where they needed you need to shine blue
lights on their on their eyes in order
for them not to have brain damage and
stuff like that and people were shining
white lights on them so again it was so
outrageous that people realize the
designs that they have where you can put
in a fluorescent light which is white or
or blue is causing jaundice in parts of
the world where people are just
replacing blue lifeboats with white flag
phones not understand they're not
solving the problem so once we
understood the real problem was how do
you prevent that it's simple you just
make LEDs blue LEDs so these kinds of
things the solutions become simple once
you realize what the right problem is we
do some executive these school and I'll
just mention two of those and then we'll
go back to our main topic of what you
can do so this happened with JetBlue was
a very popular company in the beginning
and then they were actually going to be
on Businessweek as the fourth best
company in America for in terms of
customer relations and things like that
and then what happened is it was a huge
snowstorm and their airplanes got kind
of stranded on the runways they lost
control of where the planes were so they
just shut everything down and people
weren't trapped into planes for years
and this caption said is this your first
flight with just blue showing people on
a prison and it was a disaster for the
company and they tried to work their way
around and they hired high-level
consultants and this woman who had who
is a Stanford graduate and an Olympic
athlete and is the head director of air
putting thought that you know what they
have to use as swords of the school idea
of empathy and bring together the
various groups and so she went to
management and said look I don't need
any money I just need two weeks of one
or two pilots one or two co-pilots one
or two navigators one or two baggage
handlers wanted to say I need from each
of the company's constituencies one or
two people and I need a big room and she
used this whole idea of people for the
first time talking to each other across
their boundaries within the comm
realizing how they could each support
each other in each needs and essentially
she solved the problem became a big
heroin but it had to do is this whole
idea of empathy which is you have to
talk to the people you're designing for
you have to talk to the people you're
working for and another classic example
of that and this will be my last example
came from Doug Dietz who's a longtime
designer a GE medical and he designed
MRI machines and he was horrified to
find out that children have to be
sedated at the rate of about 85% to go
into the machine and what he realized is
that he had never applied any empathy
for the children he did not look at the
machine from a child's point of view
from a child's point of view an MRI
machine is a horrible monster and you're
asked to crawl into this metallic thing
into the mouths of it and it scares them
actually my wife also gets maybe when
she goes into Ueno Zoo she so a lot of
people are scared about her and they're
noisy and children are horrified by it
so what he did when he got that
realization he went back to where he
works and he got to talk to children who
are chronic patients
he went to children's museums he went to
child psychologist and he tried to see
the whole thing from the point of view
of the user namely these children and
what they did is they didn't touch the
machines at all they just reframed the
experience and here you can see what
they did is they painted it as an
adventure right so what was a pirate
ship and you have to hold still so the
Pirates don't see you
another was going to camps you have to
hold still to see to start and the day
before he sent them a booklet explaining
looking through the body and all that in
a knapsack like you were going to camp
and it became an adventure so they
reframed and that's a very good tool
reframe your problem he reframed the
problem from how do you how do you deal
with this medical procedure into how do
you make an adventure out of this thing
and it worked so well that the sedation
rate dropped to close below 5% think
it's something like 3% in the group he
looked at and also children were
saying mommy mommy can we come back
tomorrow so he totally changed this
thing from a negative experience to a
positive experience simply by getting
empathy and reframing the problem so
another thing I want to just show you is
an example of bias towards action so
what we mean by bias towards action is
we have a clip that's called launchpad
and right in the first class these two
fellows came here's one of them and they
had this idea of making a newsreader on
an iPad and the iPad had just come out
and these students had no way to work so
they worked in cafes and everyone wanted
to try the iPad so they were able to get
immediate feedback all day long on their
their app which was a newsreader a sort
of pictorial newsreader and they could
change their coding several times a day
so they made very quick progress and
after the third week in the class the
professor said launch and they said no
no we're not ready it's not perfect and
they said launch we'll get out of the
class so they launched and immediately
sold 20,000 apps at $4 each in those
days and Steve Jobs gave him a shout-out
and they took off and just about two
years ago they sold the company for
ninety million dollars to LinkedIn so
it's a very big success story but the
main point about that is the bias
towards action the buyers to his action
was they would keep working if they were
taking this class in the business school
they probably still working on it
getting it perfect before they would
take it out and you have to move forward
even though you know it's not perfect
because you're going to learn from you
from fixing it up so that's some
examples of the kinds of tools we have
and the mainly the mindsets I'd like you
to think about now within that there are
two main things that can go wrong and
that's really the punchline of what I
really want to talk to you about this
morning and they are one is using
excuses and calling them reasons so we
use excuses and we rationalize it by
something we called reason and the
second thing that can go wrong is we mix
up the concept of trying to do something
and actually
doing something and that sort of the
subtitle of my talk today so let's delve
into these two things so the first thing
is I categorically state to you reasons
of and by that I mean reasons
for human behavior any reason you give
for your own behaviors I must
tell you I showed this slide to some
woman I know who's sort of from the old
world and she's a very gentle person as
she looked at he said oh what a horrible
word and I said ya reason this is a
horrible word but that's not what she
meant but that's what I do mean okay so
what do I mean by that well I mean you
you can't possibly know the reasons for
your behavior and but you need to have
them if someone says to you why did you
do something if I say don't know I'm not
a reasonable person so you need reasons
to seem like you're reasonable person
but in fact they're not useful and the
truth is it's usually simply an excuse
for something dysfunctional so for
example of my mouth is a little dry
right now so if you ask me Bernie why is
your mouth dry I'd say well I'm talking
so much I'm lecturing right that's a
no-brainer but what I haven't told you
is that I haven't eaten anything this
morning at all I haven't told you that
last night I drank a bottle of wine I
haven't told you I am always dehydrated
my wife's always telling me to drink
water and I haven't told you a lot of
other things which I'm embarrassed to
tell you about okay so what Bernie has
done is he's picked the one thing which
seems to make sense that I'm talking to
you and that's why I'm dry and it makes
me cool I'm a professor and all that and
all that stuff I don't tell you all the
other thing now that same truth is the
case for everything you do there's a
million reasons for anything you've done
it goes back to your childhood and maybe
even before that and you don't know the
reason you've done something so the
meaning you tell me the reason it's a
lie now it's usually a little white lie
and it's something that's fine no one
cares who cares
and it's usually if you have an image of
yourself as a good person it's something
that makes you look good if the Avenue
image of yourselves a bad ass it's
usually something
you look bad you know so whatever it is
you want you can project by selecting
that reason but the point simply is it's
always just something you have selected
it's not really why you do it you don't
you know what you've done if you're
awake and you're mindful you know what
you've done
beyond that you don't know okay so by
selecting it it's it's it's biasing the
situation this fine most the time it
doesn't matter
but sometimes reasons are simply excuses
for acting in a way that's dysfunctional
and if you're acting in a dysfunctional
way you can change that if you want to
so the idea is simply to be aware of
that and just do what you do and don't
explain it do what you do and just take
responsibility for what you do and if
you do not like what you do or did not
do don't do it again now that's more
easily said than done so the truth is if
I do something and I give you a
reason for it I'm being nice to you and
give me a reason but in my mind I say
you know I don't want to do that again
now I will do it again but eventually if
I do it enough times I'll stop doing it
if every time I do that I noticed look I
don't want why did I say that I don't
want to do that that's not really what
happened I will change my behavior it's
as simple as that it's a simple of being
mindful and having the intention to
change and giving it the attention it
needs so it's really important to
understand that most reasons get your
way and we have a joke about it where I
work we call it a good reason meaning
it's a reason and if you can
learn to get rid of reasons and not use
them you'll go a long way another thing
I want to talk to you about is trying
and trying is not the same as doing now
there's something about it that's a
little unfortunate and I hate to get and
say Yoda was wrong because I might be
struck down just sitting here but I'm
going to attempt it I think really it's
and I understand what it's about in the
movie and the Star Wars and it's great
where it is there
loves it it's sticky that's fine but
people love using the Star Wars I quote
of Yoda there's no try there's only do
and I understand but it's kind of to
type a for most people to live with
stuff like that I think you're much
better off as I believe that there is a
try and there is a do the the only
problem is that they and they both okay
they're both okay and that's I think
something you have to think about but if
you're trying then you may or may not
accomplish what you have in mind okay
that's the that's what I call a trying
state if I'm gonna try and state it
might or might work work it might work
it might work out it might not work out
but if I'm doing then if I encounter an
obstacle I mean if I'm trying my
encounter an obstacle I can be stopped I
can be stopped well if I'm doing what I
will accomplish what I have in mind
regardless the obstacles will not stop
me
they are both okay states the difficulty
comes when you think they are the same
thing okay now let me just give you a
personal anecdote in my life that just
nailed it for me so well
I was driving in San Francisco with my
wife and I noticed there's a theater
there called the Roxy theater which is a
kind of funky little theater that shows
movies you don't see anywhere else and
we were driving by and there was this
huge line you largest line I've ever
seen in front of that theater and it was
a movie about a band and it turns out
the band was there too I had never heard
of them but I thought oh this could be
really interesting so I suggested to my
wife we stopped and said no I'm tired
let's go home we had a back and forth
and eventually she acquiesced and she
said okay let's go so I said okay you
get out buy the tickets and I'll go find
a parking place so I went about ten
minutes late I came back having found
the parking place and she was standing
not in line and I said well why are you
not in wine and she said they were sold
out I said yes and she said well they
were sold out I couldn't get tickets I
said you couldn't I don't understand why
don't you get theses they was
I said stay here and then five or ten
minutes I had two tickets and we went in
and we saw the show and my wife was
right as all usual we should think god
it was awful but the point simply is my
wife was trying she was trying to
appease me she was trying to be nice
about it she really wasn't going to be
doing in terms of going to the show so
she got an obstacle they were sold out
it was absolutely true she wasn't lying
they were sold out once she hit that
obstacle that she stopped trying it was
over she wasn't doing okay I was gonna
do no matter what so it wasn't too
heroic I would have been more heroic but
it turned out to be pretty easy I walked
up and down the line I guess if anyone
had any extra tickets and someone had
just been called by a friend who said
they weren't coming so he sold me her
tickets and then as I was walking around
some guy was walking to the box office
wanting to return a ticket my border
from him but even if it wasn't that easy
there is some amount of money with
someone the missions if sick would sell
many tickets okay and if I were going to
do and no matter what I would come up
with that amount of money and it's as
simple as that it's a simple of whatever
it takes I've been at the airport where
they tell me a flight is canceled to
somewhere if I don't want to actually go
on that trip if I'm going because I
should or I have to I'm elated
I'm blocked I tried I go into the
airport this is gnosis an actual true
story but if I were really doing you
know there are ways of getting there
even though the plane isn't flying there
and if my life depended on it I would
get there so it's a simple example of
this whole idea of the difference
between trying and doing and it's a lot
of fun to try I'm not against it a lot
of times I try and it's good it's it's
just to realize they're not the same
thing so it can be fun to try and not
succeed you don't always have to succeed
I like I love to lose sometimes some
people go crazy if they lose I love to
lose I actually in social things with
friends you know I love to play Scrabble
and
worry about drinking rather than winning
the Scrabble game and I have friends who
just want to win the Scrabble game and
all and I enjoy the whole show you know
it doesn't bother me
maybe you're different than you but you
just have to not kid yourself that
someone else has stopped you you just
need to realize that if you do not
succeed you choose to be trying rather
than doing that's the key to the whole
thing and I think that's the way you
should look at it and at times it's
better to try and not succeed than it is
to succeed and it might even save your
life at times so sometimes succeeding
can get you into a lot of trouble so
just be careful what you ask for
and I would say mellow out and don't you
don't have to be Yoda all the time but
when you want to be don't use excuses
and don't let yourself off the hook and
you have to know your intention what is
my intention what is I want to
accomplish what do I want to do and if
you're going to do it you have to give
it attention it requires time those guys
who did the embrace that children
sleeping there it took years of hard
work even though they had a brilliant
idea the brilliant idea may work right
away
in general it's not it's going to be
commitment it's going to be doing hard
work is a part of creativity it's one of
the most important parts of it if you
read the stories about these big
achievers like Steve Jobs or Elon Musk
these guys never sleep I mean they're
working all the time they're not kicking
back and smoking cigars and all that
there's a different type of person as a
different type of DNA you don't have to
be that extreme but you have to be the
appropriate DNA for you choose to do to
have a good life so when you the thing
to realize I've come to realize when you
try you're using force and when you do
you're using power and in life it is
much better to be powerful to be
forceful and if you think about that
it's that way it's not just yanking back
and forth when you're trying to do
something if you do it you knock your
opponent on their backside without much
effort if you're efforting it's a trying
thing you might succeed you might not
succeed but if someone is powerful
there's no there's no doubt what they're
going to do and if you see that around
you it's just awesome and that's kind of
the behavior you want to do and I just
got this letter July 3rd which is not
far away this is she wrote it
was written on third so I got it it was
this is a snail mail letter from a woman
who is in her 80s who used to be a
professor of the university okay so
she's an accomplished woman and she read
my book and she wrote me the story and
the story is she said my they were
husband was a professor and she couldn't
get a job course in those days there was
nepotism and discrimination unit which
goes way back before she even got her
first teaching my husband I'll take out
the identified needed a freshly washed
and ironed white dress shirt every
morning ironing his shirt came to
symbolize my circumscribed life and then
she goes on to account the dream she had
where she's out in the Midwest and his
flowing fields and the open spaces and
everything like that but she was chained
up and couldn't go and move anything and
she rushed then she writes writing about
this dream in my daily journal I
recognize Kafka's prisoner who was
confined only and by his own choice the
insight came everything we do we have
chosen to do by default or a decision
and that was her insight years ago which
led ultimately to becoming the president
of a pretty big College and all that so
it's just and I think that's really a
powerful thing to realize that you're in
charge folks you know to me and you can
do or not do it doesn't matter it's okay
but it should just serve your function
and you don't have to be a college
president you could be a college janitor
you couldn't not even know what a
college is it doesn't matter it's just
whatever will serve your life is where
you want to get to and you don't want to
have this functional behaviors and
excuses and reasons can be dysfunctional
and I just would like you to be aware of
that and you don't have to be as
extremist Lee I do not use reasons I do
not give everyone reasons I just had
another example of that this morning I
get I get endless requests from students
that want to come and do PhDs with me
from all over the world and what I used
to do is give them reasons and I get a
lot of pushback and oh my phone I like
to say if I said it didn't have money oh
I have a rich uncle it goes on and on
and
endless email now I've gotten this thing
I don't give reasons I said I'm sorry I
can't help you good luck to you and this
I just did it there you go and this
morning I got what I usually get Thank
You professor for answering my email
that's the Android conversation I get I
get this are the neither hear from them
again or I get thank you for answering
my email and that's fine I'm happy with
that and it's so functional for me and
it just clears the air and it doesn't
get their expectations up and stuff like
that and any reason I give a student for
not taking this because if I
wanted to take a student I could take
them no matter what so it's just a lie I
just for some reason which I don't know
or 4,000 reasons not doing it just say
what you're gonna do try it out and see
how that works for you so the other
thing is language is kind of important
and what you have to do what you have to
do with languages be a little careful
and my book I talk a lot about I just
want to mention certain obvious things
so if you say you have to it's
disempowering if you have to do
something if someone's making you do it
but if you say I want to it's really
empowering and the truth is you do as
this woman said in her letter to me
everything they're doing is chosen to do
it either by electing to do it or by
electing not to do it so if you're going
to do it you really want to do it what
you know maybe all sorts a reason it
doesn't matter you're doing it so you
want to do it and if you don't want to
do it don't do it
it's as simple and that kind of simple
change your phrase is very empowering I
can't I can't do it I won't do it again
it's much more powering to say you won't
do it then I can't do it can't do it as
a wimp out thing and it disempowers you
and the other words I have many more but
the other one I love is the use of but
versus an so most of time in our
language you use but like I'd like to
stop the talk to keep talking to you but
my time is up I might say and it's
really existential situations I like to
keep talking to you and my time is up so
there's no those are two things which
are existentially true
so we usually take two phrases which
your eggs essentially true we combine
with the butt and it nullifies the thing
I remember I was in Tokyo and I gave
this wonderful talk and so on gets up in
the audience at the end he says Bernie
that was a wonderful talk but bava bava
and the butt is of course negates that
he thought it was a wonderful talk you
know and he it isn't that he was being
nasty to me it's just the way people use
language but if he said bring I was a
wonderful talk and it was I wouldn't
sell much better about it okay you get
the idea
okay so what I would like to keep
talking to you and we're now at the
point where Ryan is going to talk to you
for a bit and after that we're going to
take questions for you guys but before I
do that I want to just make sure you
understand the point of it I want you to
make sure that you make sure you're
working on a real problem and disappear
it if you can
don't use reasons for your behavior just
notice what you've done and take
responsibility for it and if your
attentions to do do it don't try to do
it and then after that I want to also
tell you about my book which is called
the achievement habit which is this is
the front cover and if you're interested
in I have a really nice website about it
cool which is essentially achievement
habit one word.com
and it came out just about two weeks ago
from HarperCollins and you can get it
any way you want
hopefully and it does a lot of the
things I talked about here so thanks for
everyone for listening and being out
there and I hope you have a good rest of
the day